This is an article published by the Guardian
back in 2014 ― It’s an obituary for Australia’s
Great Barrier Reef.
Two years later, Outside magazine published this ― it’s...
another obituary for the reef.
And more recently, we got this news:
BBC News: And also this hour, the Great Barrier Reef is at a terminal stage.
Have we really killed the Great Barrier Reef?
The answer is no… but we sure are trying.
It’d be hard to call the time of death for
the Great Barrier Reef because it’s actually some 3,000 reefs
spread over an area the size of Italy.
So there’s plenty of room right now for
there to be widespread damage and lots of
relatively healthy reefs ― that’s something
dive operators there really want you to know.
“The contrast in colors down there and the
water ― when the light hits the different
colors down there and yeah it’s absolutely
amazing.”
But the world’s coral reefs, including the
Great Barrier Reef, have had a really hard
time the past few years.
After decades of degradation from local threats like pollution, and overfishing ―
coral reefs have now also undergone a record-breaking
“global bleaching event.”
That’s when coral turns white, which puts
them at a high risk of dying.
It started in 2014, during the Northern Hemisphere
summer.
Abnormally warm water caused corals in Guam
and the Northern Mariana Islands to start
bleaching en masse.
By the end of 2014, corals around Hawaii,
Florida and the Marshall Islands
were bleaching too.
When summer came around in the Southern Hemisphere, bleaching spreads to coral reefs
in the South Pacific and the Indian Ocean.
And towards the end of 2015, corals throughout
the Caribbean were bleached too.
Hawaii’s corals bleached for a second time.
By now El Nino was in full force, and when
combined with global warming, it kept sea
temperatures high enough to continue the bleaching
event into 2016, hitting corals in Asia,
the east coast of Africa, and ... the Great
Barrier Reef too
― the worst bleaching, in fact, that the
Great Barrier Reef had ever seen.
Bleaching continued into 2017, when the Great
Barrier Reef was hit, again.
ABC News: Australia’s Great Barrier Reef in grave
condition tonight...
FOX News: For the second year in a row, this
video showing bleaching…
BBC News: Two-thirds of the Great Barrier Reef
has now been devastated by severe coral bleaching
which is caused by rising water temperatures.
Researchers first documented global coral
bleaching in 1998 ― a record warm year ―
and it happened again in 2010.
But this third global bleaching event is by
far the worst.
And looking at this temperature trend, you
can get why people are starting to say goodbye
to coral reefs.
But to really get what makes them vulnerable,
you have to understand how coral reefs work.
Corals are related to jellyfish and sea anemones,
but you’ve probably noticed that they don’t
look quite as... squishy.
There are a couple reasons for that.
For one thing, they live in colonies.
Each coral structure is made of hundreds or
thousands of individual
coral animals called polyps.
Each of these little bumps is where a polyp
lives.
They’re easy to overlook if you’re snorkeling
but if you look closely, you can see them,
especially at night when they’re less likely
to be hiding.
Those polyps build a skeleton together.
Not all corals do this but the ones that build
reefs do so by creating a calcium carbonate
skeleton underneath them, layer by layer.
So the living polyps sit in little cups on
top of an ever-expanding skeleton structure
which, in turn, sits on top of the compacted
skeletons of previous corals from thousands
of years ago, otherwise known as limestone.
By building these structures with all these
nooks and crannies, corals provide homes for
hundreds of other animals and plants ― an
estimated 25% of all marine species,
even though they take up less than 1% of the ocean floor.
Those reefs provide billions of dollars worth
of economic value to people every year, through
fisheries, tourism, and protection from storm
waves.
But here’s the thing: corals can’t build
reefs on their own.
Coral reefs exist because of an incredible
partnership between animal and plant.
That’s because reef-building corals get
the majority of their energy and nutrients
from single-celled algae that live inside
coral polyps.
It’s where they get their greenish-brown
color too.
They’re called zooxanthellae, and like other
plants, they make energy from sunlight, that’s
why coral reefs mostly grow near the surface
of the ocean ― where the sun shines.
But this partnership breaks down under heat
stress.
After multiple weeks of temperatures even
just a couple degrees celsius hotter than
the maximum temperature that they’re used to,
The photosynthetic system in the algae starts
to accumulate reactive oxygen molecules like
hydrogen peroxide,
which leak into the coral polyp cells.
To protect themselves from damage, the coral
polyps kick the algae out of their bodies,
leaving the pale skeleton showing through.
By warming the planet, we are, among many
other things, breaking up the team that built
the ocean’s most diverse ecosystem.
But bleached corals don’t necessarily die.
What happens next depends on how severe and
long-lasting the high temperatures are.
When researchers assessed the damage to the
Great Barrier Reef in 2016,
they found that coral death was concentrated
in the northern section of the reef, where
bleaching had been the most severe.
In the central section, 33% of the reefs bleached
severely, but there was only around 6% mortality.
That’s because zooxanthellae can return
to a coral colony within a few weeks if the
water cools back down fast enough.
If not, the coral dies from starvation or
disease.
If enough coral colonies die, a reef can get
taken over by fuzzy brown seaweed.
Some coral reefs have transformed into…
this.
If there are enough fish and other grazers
to eat up the seaweed, new coral larvae can
settle there and the reef can start building
up again.
After the 1998 bleaching, the corals of the
Great Barrier Reef eventually recovered.
But it takes a decade or more for even the
fastest growing corals to build back up, and
that 10 year timeline assumes one very important
condition:
That they don’t bleach all over again.
And they almost certainly will.
Climate models project that in the coming
decades, the conditions now causing mass bleaching
will become increasingly frequent, until eventually
they happen every summer.
How soon that happens depends a lot on whether
we start cutting our greenhouse gas emissions.
If we don’t, annual bleaching conditions
are projected for parts of
the Great Barrier Reef by mid-century.
At that point, few coral reefs could survive.
If we buy them more time by slowing down global
warming, corals and their zooxanthellae may
be able to acclimate or eventually evolve
to tolerate warmer weather.
Coral reefs would still change, and probably
still shrink,
but we could give them a better chance.
That’s why it doesn’t make sense to pronounce
them dead.
This ecosystem is dynamic.
There are forces building it up, that are  battling the forces tearing it down,
and those factors vary by species & by location.
But with global warming, humans have sided
against the world’s coral reefs
to an unprecedented degree.
Some of the damage is now unavoidable.
But the battle isn’t over, and it’s not
too late for us switch sides.
If you’d like to learn more about what the
climate change is doing to the biodiversity
of our planet ― go over to audible.com/vox.
Their massive collection of audio books includes a lot of titles about climate change, including
“The Sixth Extinction: An Unnatural History.”
This is a Pulitzer Prize-winning book by Elizabeth
Kolbert, covering not just coral reefs ―
but animals and plants around the world that are
struggling to keep up with environmental change.
You can sign up for a free 30-day trial at
audible.com/vox, and if you decide not to
continue on with them ― you still get to
keep your book.
So sign up at audible.com/vox
and start spending your commute, or your cooking time, or your cleaning time,
learning more about the role
that our species is playing
in the history of life on Earth.